ich stehe auf einem alten friedhof
das ist ein grabstein
ich sehe einen grabstein das werk sehen
wird im deutschen immer mit dem
akkusativ gebildet es gibt vier fälle im
deutschen seminar tief in die tiefe
positiv für den akkusativ müsst ihr
wissen dass ich immer nur der männliche
fall verändert ich sehe eine frau ich
sehe ein kind ich sehe einen mann
das üben jetzt das ist der baum
das ist ein kleiner baum das ist ein
großer baum
ich sehe den baum
ich umarme dem baum gerne sagt das ist
eine sehr wichtige vokabel auf deutsch
und er wollte schon immer wissen wie das
auf deutsch heißt deswegen zeigen wir es
euch hier das ist der baumstumpf ich
klettere auf dem baumstumpf das sind
fliegen eine fliege viele fliegen
ich sehe viele fliegen
das fängt mir eine blume ich bekomme
eine blume es ist aber lieb von dir
jannis wir haben gerade auf dem friedhof
am hre getroffen er ist ein risiko hin
zuschauer aus ägypten
was machst du in berlin er ist wird so
eine partie war und was machst du dir
ich mache mich atronic ausbildung bei
siemens dann viel spaß bei der party mit
den vielen dank
ich sehe schilder auf den schildern
steht was alles verboten ist
grillen ist verboten hunde sind verboten
radfahren ist verboten und eltern müssen
auf ihre kinder aufpassen
ich sehe eine tram
die tram fährt ab
ich schwitze in einer bushaltestelle
ich flehe eine baby mütze ich sehe ist
eine super ich sehe einen pizzakarton
ich sehe eine zigarettenschachtel
ich sehe einen prospekt das ist ein
motorrad das motorrad ich sehe ein foto
[Musik]
das ist eine baustelle
die baustelle wird um freund mit zäunen
es bis unklar was hier um freund wird in
der baustelle gibt es keine
das ist der mülleimer
ich sehe den mülleimer das ist der
karton
mehr
mülleimer ist orange karton ist blau
ich stecke den blauen karton in den
orangenen mülleimer das ist ein plakat
das plakat auf dem plakat steht
achtung lebensgefahr januar trat in
lebensgefahr
denn er steht auf dem fahrradweg das ist
ein stein der stein was sie richtig sehe
einen stein ins meer
sogar viele steine was brauche ich um
diese straße zu bauen
ich brauche viele steine was wäre ich
auf janosch entwerfe einen stein
was ist das das ist der banker was sehe
ich
ich will den acker was kann janus nicht
fahren
janus kann keinen bagger fahren das ist
das schaufenster von einem schönen
hipster geschäft in dem schaufenster
sehe ich fortschritte sachen in dem
schaufenster wie ich ein bild mit der
karte von berlin in dem schaufenster
schwierig eine schüssel in dem
schaufenster sehe ich stifte
in dem schaufenster sehe ich einen
zettel mit öffnungszeiten in den
schaufenstern sehe ich ein buch in dem
schaufenster sehe ich ein bild das war
unser neues video in dem wir viele dinge
gesehen haben wenn ihr lust habt könnt
ihr unseren kanal abonnieren das könnte
hier machen oder ihr könnt ein mitglied
bei uns werden und uns unterstützen das
könnt ihr machen
darüber würden wir uns sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr sehr toll freuen
dankeschön und bis nächste woche
tschüss